[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
today's theme on the ramsey show
stirring up a holy ruckus i love it
george campbell is my co-host today and
uh he started off this week stirring up
the holy ruckus we uh downloaded a new
episode of i think there's ten episodes
of the fine print uh a new podcast that
we have here that where if you read the
fine print it will make you
pissed off at an industry that's
screwing you yeah you need to read the
fine print and or just things that
people believe that are false right oh
yeah you're digging into them and
today's
is a beehive
george dared to expose
the mythology
around bitcoin will make you rich
down yeah this is going to be a youtube
highlight i can already see the comments
i see the vision of comments dave here's
the thing i took a baseball bat to the
beehive of cryptocurrency to help people
understand what it is and you've talked
about it on air you're not the
anti-crypto but we're
anti-get-rich-quick we're
anti-short-term thinking and the world
of cryptocurrency is so confusing even
for smart people and people are just
diving in throwing money at this thing
and it's becoming the next roulette
table yeah if your money's named after a
dog
it could be a problem dogecoin there it
is and it's not even it's not even
pronounced properly i know but it's a
meme it's a whole thing
again
yeah it's a wild world so check it out
the new podcast uh this is the fourth
episode i think the fifth or sixth i'm
losing track now we've got a total of
ten yeah in the can and so you it's a
new podcast on the ramsey network called
the fine print be sure and check it out
today's hour we're going to stir up
another holy ruckus one of my favorite
things to trash
crime shares i mean time shares you
mispronounce it wait you didn't yeah no
i didn't uh fleecing a car i did not
mispronounce either it's leasing a car
but i understand but
one of my buddies calls it crime shares
because it is the largest legalized
fraud in america today 10 billion
dollars of ripping off old people and
people that couldn't afford to buy their
own vacation so they went in the tiger
cage and got a tiger and bought a time
share
why are people still doing this i don't
understand
control so if you've been ripped off by
the timeshare industry or you love your
timeshare if you want to call in and
tell us how much you love it if you have
just done the timeshare thing love it or
not we're going to talk about timeshares
this hour lots
to talk about lots to talk about in the
news you've got a whole stack of papers
here and i got papers all over my desk
and i usually have none i usually just
take your calls and we do it but this is
uh this is such an interesting thing
here's a brand new article just came out
uh so
staff sergeant mike lowe had just
returned from a six-month deployment
home to his wife siobhan and their
six-month-old child they were looking
for some better life balance this was a
good idea
to force it to take us a yearly vacation
he thought
this was a time share so instead of
honoring the lowe's military service the
salesperson for the timeshare operator
windham
leveraged it as a sales pitch they
played off the thing of you deploy and
it might be a year or two before you see
each other they said this might be a
good opportunity to ensure that you use
that valuable time wow
praying on a young military family is a
new low even for timeshare nightmare
stories
the low
uh tale sounds too familiar a
manipulative sales pitch accompanied by
false promises fine print there it is
yes and fees lots of fees
the lows ended up losing about 20
thousand dollars and got virtually
nothing in return from wyndham shortly
after they signed wyndham told them the
program had changed shocking
and they couldn't use the properties
they'd signed up for but the dumpy ones
were available i put that in there and a
new plan at even greater expense could
provide what they wanted so you can
upgrade if you're stupid enough to get
screwed twice yeah i added that too it
also it all led to some unbearable
stress mentally and emotionally it put a
lot of strain on our marriage not to
mention their careers with the lows
struggling to make the mortgage payments
they worried about bad credit hurting
their security clearance threatening
their military status and then the
reality hit that what they signed meant
for their children would take over the
deed and the ever-increasing fees came
with the program i felt like we were a
prisoner
to
windham said mike lowe staff sergeant
mike lowe
after serving his country this is the
way that windham
served him
wow
i can't even believe this this is a real
article yeah and make it up
timeshare nightmares from newsherald.com
uh man pretty incredible
absolutely
over the top this uh you know the thing
is you go into the tiger cage that's
what i call it because so what's
happening is and most of you have heard
this pitch or some of you have done it
um didn't you tell me you did it one
time i almost did it and i was like i'm
going to say no and get the free good i
don't have to smack you
i almost fell for the pitch i didn't
almost fall for the timeshare just
because i thought i'm i'm good but then
i realized i don't want to spend four
hours of my vacation
with some sleazeburger they have to take
a shower after going in there
oh my gosh no here's the thing you know
we you're walking along the street and
the zoo manager runs out and says hey a
free pass to the zoo for a year all you
have to do is go in the tiger cage and
sit with the tiger and pet him for an
hour
note the tiger's not been fed in three
days and he's a bit greedy at this
moment
this is what you're doing when you go
into a time share sales pitch
because they know if you get out the
door the chances of them ever closing
the sale is zero
and so they will
do anything legal illegal they will do
any kind of manipulative tactic one hour
turns into four hours turns into eight
hours they ship old people in on buses
for these presentations from nursing
homes they really do do this oh yeah i
mean diamond international some of the
stuff mike flasky and that team did was
unbelievable note though uh that has now
been sold to the good people over at
hilton they paid a billion dollars to
buy the largest timeshare company in the
world diamond international and word on
the street is i've not been able to
verify that mike flasky and his
executive team all got fired wow mr
timeshare himself
so um
i kind of popped him on twitter a couple
times and said hey mikey and he went hey
davey so we had a little fun going back
and forth and uh pretty much telling him
what i thought of his ripoff crook
industry and now he's out of a job
because hilton bought them and they are
trying to clean up the reputation of
diamond
oh you're gonna need a big scoop for all
that poop buddy i'm just saying
that's uh hilton you've done messed up
you stepped in it and you're gonna have
to shovel shovel shovel shelves but then
you'll still at the end of the day be in
the timeshare business hilton yeah
not good which means they're going to be
making more than a billion dollars off
of this
they wouldn't put a billion into it if
they weren't going to make more out it
is a money-making scheme however several
stockholders objected to the sale at
hilton and wanted them to not close on
it it did close and they did fire flasky
who's pretty much a glorified
yeah i was going to call me use car
salesman
i'd be an upgrade a bit i'd be putting
down my friends that sell used cars i
mean golly no this is just a it's a
horrible nasty
industry have you ever seen the
documentary of the queen of versailles
oh yeah look that one up talk about what
i thought you were going to say have you
seen tiger king well it's right there
it's right there buddy now the queen of
versailles is about the wife of one of
the billionaire owners of westgate oh
yeah yeah ma taking your calls
on
timeshares this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
tonight george and christy and christy
wright and i will all be doing together
the game plan
live stream it's a free live stream
happening tonight at 7 00 p.m central
time you do not have to settle for
normal not normal with managing your
time managing your goals or managing
your money the three of us are going to
talk you through that uh and so be
prepared to sit down with some popcorn
and uh whatever else you need to sit
through
a little bit of life change baby we're
going to give you a game plan tonight at
7 00 p.m central uh and there's a couple
of seats left here in the auditorium for
those that want to be here in person uh
you can check out all of that so to
register for game plan live text
we're going to give you gameplay game
plan text game plan 233
789 33789
so george we know that timeshares are
among the top 10 scams that cost older
americans the most according to the aarp
number seven timeshare sales 17.4
million and number 10 timeshare resales
12 and a half million so a 30 million
dollar hit on the elderly which is
primarily what they prey on among other
people who are willing to go into the
tiger cage all right let's take some
calls from you if you've got a time
share and want to talk about the phone
number's triple eight eight two five
five two two five this hour is dedicated
to the timeshare business
oh natalie's with us in dallas texas hey
natalie tell us your story
thank you dave it's an honor to speak
with you you too
my timeshare star story started back in
2012
my now ex-husband and i went to a
timeshare presentation and he thought he
was smarter than they were so we bought
ours off of ebay for five thousand
instead of threw them at their price
then about then about two years later
which company
with marriott oh
oh oh
yeah then then about two years later we
purchased another one this time for 4
500.
uh in the end we had two weeks at the
marriott out in
hawaii on
the
near coalina
we used it for many years without any
problems but once we decided to trade
our weeks in that's when we discovered
it was not as wonderful as they had
claimed it was
it would cost more money and it was very
hard to get availability at the location
as nice as ours was
fast forward to 2016 and we ended up
getting divorced
i gave my ex-husband both of the
timeshares
i thought it would just be the fact of
marriott taking my name off their
records
but once i contacted marriott i found
out the deeds needed to be changed along
with filing paperwork with marriott and
then paying another fee to them of
course
yeah luckily i worked for a real estate
attorney so i was familiar with the
process
and could do the deeds and filings
myself with um the county out in hawaii
so after eight months i finally get the
deeds back from hawaii and i send them
off to marriott
after marriott cash my check several
weeks went by and they sent me an email
saying that one of our deeds was wrong
and they would not be removing my name
until it was changed and re-recorded
and you had to pay another fee of course
no i was beyond mad at this point
i mean
it's easier to get rid of the ex-husband
than marriott
it was it was that's so true
and and i knew that and i knew the deeds
were correct you know
so i went as i went right to the better
business bureau and filed a complaint
i was contacted right away by marriott
vacation club by an executive there
and
and i let them know matter of factly
what exactly was needed on a deed to be
recorded
and that i had two legal documents
stating that i was not the owner and
that no court of law would ever hold me
liable for these
then i also let them know that by
cashing my check they were now in breach
of contract since they had not performed
the work they promised
they agreed with me and within a few
hours that i had my name return removed
um from from both these time shares
and now i'm working um to make sure that
my son doesn't inherit these yeah and
and to ultimately educate others uh
about what can happen but that's what
these companies do like marriott they're
big and they you know the only thing
they respond to is getting the crap
smacked out of them that gets their
attention and then suddenly an executive
grows a backbone and a little bit of
integrity and calls you up instead they
had put in place entire systems to make
sure you couldn't get out of the rat
maze
and what people don't don't know is that
i you know i called the department that
handles the transfer of the deeds none
of the people there
knew anything about uh about deets they
knew nothing about special warranty
deeds about you know property
you're saying that marriott's timeshare
transfer divisions incompetent
shocking
[Laughter]
uh yes i i felt that they were so
yeah and and not proper you know not
they're not properly educated so
they are as you said they're trying to
bully people who maybe aren't educated
also they're expecting them to
you know
be the ones who know what to do
and they don't so i i felt very very
fortunate that i did have that legal
background to be able to push back and
and get this done so george when i was a
kid
part is you feel hopeless when they do
this to you oh yeah it beats the snot
out of you but not you because when i
was a kid i had this bulldog that would
grab a towel and shake it you know oh
yeah and she would bite onto it so hard
that you could lift her off the ground
that's natalie
you know a little bit she got a hold of
it she ain't letting go until they gonna
do they're gonna do what they're
supposed to do you can knock you can try
to knock me down but i've already got
rid of the ex-husband i'm getting rid of
you too marriott look at you girl she
advocated for herself way to go natalie
that's awesome most people are not gonna
do that and they're hoping for that and
they know that's what's gonna happen is
most people just go well whatever i
don't know the process i'll just deal
with it i'll just pay it and natalie way
to go to fight for yourself and get out
of this nightmare i mean it took you you
had what 150 to 300 hours invested in
this process just to get out of it
it took it took months and months in
hawaii because hawaii has
loads and loads of documents that have
to be filled out that people would not
understand so most people have to have
an attorney
do this and try finding an attorney who
you're in hawaii i'm here in texas
it wouldn't have been easy if if i
didn't have that background and so
for other people
it you know keep fighting you know and
to get away from this stuff
yeah and that's after you bought one for
almost nothing on ebay
uh well they're pretty much giving them
away over there yeah now they are now
you can buy them for two dollars if
you'll just get me out if you'll just
take me off the deed get rid of my my uh
dadgum monthly maintenance fee which
they go up on every freaking year um you
know if i can get away from marriott for
three dollars that's a deal they'll sell
them for three dollars on ebay
because that include included all the um
closing costs with the
at the title company oh wow wow
yeah
cray cray wow thanks for sharing your
story natalie um it's fairly typical
uh it's it's a it's an industry that has
a dissatisfaction level among its
customers is so high that there are
almost no repeat customers yeah no one
has four time shares and if they do
they're they're deep in this thing now
when we talk to somebody occasionally it
does and they're just they're really
into it but they're they're a super
super super small percentage
almost everyone the survey that we had
the ramsey research team do some surveys
we'll cover some of those numbers later
in the hour
uh and you know
if uh if euros dissatisfaction level
with the ramsey show was even a
just a millisecond as high as the we'd
be out of business oh yeah but these
people just keep on shoveling you would
think it'd be a sign if it's on ebay for
a dollar that it's probably not that it
probably sucks
yeah that's about the price of a beanie
baby right now on ebay
there's another one yeah just keep
bringing them up be on the right side of
history all right get don't do this
thing
oh
man
the beanie baby investment craze of the
1990s
my kid will go to college i'm storing up
beanie babies
beanie babies and bitcoin all in one
hour oh
what a show
crime shares i mean time shares that's
what we're concentrating on this hour
here on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host he's the host of our latest
podcast on the ramsey networks called
the fine print
be sure and listen to this week's
episode on bitcoin it will be at minimum
interesting to you
we're talking crime shares i mean time
shares this hour america's largest
legalized fraud
over 10 billion people have been screwed
by the timeshare business
uh and what are you buying when you buy
a timeshare air
i got it i got it ding ding george got
it one more time say it say it louder
for the people in the back you're buying
air okay
expensive air and if you add up if you
if you end up paying 14 000 ford and you
finance it and you add up your payments
you're paying 782 dollars a night on
average to stay there oh and that's if
you can get your week and if you can get
over there at the right time and that's
if they don't go up on the maintenance
fees and that's a lot iff and a lot of
ifs and buts yeah and uh i'm just saying
it's a problem and
782 a night will get you a pretty decent
hotel room most places in the world and
you can travel wherever you like
and you are not handcuffed to stupidity
jennifer is with us in cincinnati ohio
jennifer tell us your time share story
hi dave i'm happy to talk to you about
my timeshare story cool um in 1996 my
cousin invited me to go with her to
florida she had this great deal with a
nice place to stay and okay fine a week
in florida happy to you know
so
they were really targeting her until
they figured out that i was gainfully
employed i own my own home so then they
were on the attack for both of us
well my dad taught me probably when i
was 17
in
purchasing a car
don't let them see a sweat be a rock
don't give in don't look like you're
dying to buy this car
so i was stellar you know i resisted we
walked out of there i felt so good about
us that we didn't fall for their
timeshare
by
and it worked on me overnight everything
they said all of the lies all of the
trickery and i went back there the next
day and bought a timeshare went and
sought them out the next day
you all you got out of the time you got
out of the tiger cage alive yeah and he
went back and petted him again
went right back in the part they got me
was that they you know
when they try to sell you something
they start really high and then they go
lower and lower and lower they offered
me to own my
my timeshare every other year
so i would only own on the odd years and
instead of fifteen thousand dollars it
was only going to be seventy five
hundred dollars so that sounded really
good
until that first year
after i purchased i got hit with a
maintenance fee
and i thought well they've made a
mistake i'll call them up and there's no
maintenance field a year that i don't
stay there i don't know
this is the evening
no
maintenance fees were every single year
yeah and they charge you the full
maintenance fee probably yeah not a half
yes four maintenance fee 20 250
and by the time we got rid of it it was
almost to 500
it was funny too so that was in 96 i met
my husband in 97 he proposed in 99 and i
said oh we can go to hawaii i own a time
share so proud of myself well we
couldn't go to hawaii on that timeshare
they didn't have availability no no you
know the kid goes back to florida which
was nice i mean we paid a lot of money
to go to hawaii on our honeymoon which
was nice
but i felt so cheated because i owned a
timeshare i should be able to go
wherever i want i mean there you go they
sold me on other countries and
you know exotic places that never
happened
um
we we traveled on it four times we owned
it until 2014
and in addition to that monthly
maintenance rci had their hand in it too
you had to be in good standing with rci
and that was a hundred dollars a year
but if you bought three years at once
they'd lower it to 75. that's a good
deal so every few years you get a you
know two who was the company you
actually bought the time share from
windham
and it i'll tell you it was a beautiful
place they were a yacht club they owned
two yachts that you could go to florida
and take 20 of your friends out on the
yacht for the day who knows did you ever
get on one of my friends never not one
time never rode the boat nope never rode
the boat never got to go out on the
yacht and one point
a hurricane
affected the resort
and i thought oh we're out of it they
had a time shareholders meeting in
florida and they were voting to see are
they going to knock this building down
are they going to pay the money to
repair it
and i voted by proxy was knock it down
and everybody would be out of it at that
point they repaired it i still owned it
we didn't get out of it it took
what 18 years until
because wyndham still owned the majority
of the shares yeah and they voted you
guys voted against you guys i'm sure
they did i'm sure they didn't know
absolutely yeah
people found that out at covid too that
if you couldn't go because of covet it
didn't matter you still got charged
right right and and that was the thing
when the hurricane hit
while the entire two years that that
building was under repair
i had no travel rights whatsoever of
course none and i couldn't even sell my
week to go elsewhere because i didn't
have a week to sell because that
building was under repair it was the
biggest rip-off
and
by the grace of god we did finally get
out of it but it cost us money even to
get out of it
yeah how did you get out
we got a postcard in the mail from a
company that was holding meetings um
in the northern kentucky area to come
hear what they had to offer about
getting out of a time how much did you
pay to get out i think it was several
thousand dollars
that's a typical that's a typical exit
fee and the time share industry has gone
after the exit companies big time and
after the attorneys
that get people out of the timeshares
one of those attorneys is on the line
jennifer thank you for calling and
sharing your story scott montgomery is
one of the attorneys out of springfield
missouri that actively gets people out
of timeshares and when we're doing a
crime share hour we always bring scott
on because he's an expert on this stuff
scott how are you my friend
i'm great dave how are you doing good
doing good so uh i was reading in my
notes here preparing for the show
and it was uh talking about the subprime
home lending crisis in 2008 that
dodd-frank act was supposed to
fix uh but we've got a similar lending
crisis happening again that dodd-frank
does not apply to
because the timeshare industry lobbied
and got all of their debt not subject to
dodd-frank so they've got all the
subprime money on the books right
yes that's exactly right dave that
that's something that most people in
this country they don't know that that
is going on but you have similar players
that caused the subprime home lending
crash back in 2008 that they're now
engaged in in the same type of lending
because there was a one-term congressman
from florida and he snuck two words into
the exclusions from dodd-frank he snuck
in the words time share mortgages so
dodd-frank which was designed to cure
all of the lending problems that caused
that crash back in 2008
it doesn't apply to timeshare mortgages
so you have the same culprit doing the
same thing so let me guess if we looked
at that uh congressman's
uh
donations
for his political campaign we might find
some large entry entries from the
timeshare business
boy if i had to bet the farm on it i i
bet we would
yeah because i bet the little sucker's
not that crafty on his own he was a
brand new congressman
a lot of them aren't that bright
right right and you can bet that his uh
campaign contributions we know where
they came from they came from the
billion dollar time share pushers so you
think that's why some of the state
attorneys generals are acting like
they're acting uh in the federal uh
consumer financial protection bureau
this is supposed to protect consumers
they're not doing anything
at all
and the attorneys general some of them
are coming down the wrong side they're
coming after the exit team
exit people rather than the timeshare
people and do you think it's got to do
with political contributions
i do i i think it probably does and i i
don't want to paint with that broad of a
brush and put every state attorney
general in the same category no just the
ones that are supporting the timeshare
business
they're on the wrong side of the
argument they're supposed to be for the
consumer
absolutely you know they've picked the
wrong side if they're backing a billion
dollar timeshare pusher over a consumer
absolutely absolutely hang on we're
going to talk a little bit more after
this break scott montgomery is an
attorney in the business of exiting
people from the timeshares
and uh he gets sued regularly by the
timeshare business for doing this
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
george campbell's my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five scott montgomery with
springfield an attorney in springfield
missouri is on the line who uh actually
sues timeshare companies and gets sued
by them as a result to get people out
threatens to sue them to get people out
because of the fraudulent activities so
scott what is the latest on the
timeshare front these days it's been a
little while since i've talked to you
what are you seeing and hearing out
there
well the the lawsuits against uh
timeshare
uh exit attorneys they're they're
proceeding
and uh we're
we're hanging in there they've been
picking off some law firms one by one so
it is difficult to try and find an
attorney to represent you if you are a
timeshare owner who who has exited from
the tiger cage and now owns a timeshare
another another thing we're also seeing
is that big banks are getting involved
with timeshare mortgages and you are
likely to walk out of the tiger cage
with a new credit card a brand new
credit card which has been maxed out to
the tune of let's say 50 000
and that money has been used to purchase
a time share which has no value and
which you probably can't use because
it's been oversold
wow
so when the uh the
a-r-d-a
which is the time share industries
association correct
uh the trustee richard sargent
threatened on behalf of arda to
eradicate
timeshare
exit firms and the rumor was on the
street that they had promised they would
put tens of millions of dollars up for
the purpose of
running people out of the business that
do exits like you that help people get
out of the timeshares that was true
wasn't it
oh that was absolutely true and the you
know the billion-dollar timeshare
pushers have absolutely spent tens of
millions of dollars trying to put small
law firms like mine out of business and
if i was the shareholder of one of those
timeshare
pushing companies you know they're
publicly traded if i was a shareholder i
would be furious that my money has been
wasted trying to pursue these
companies that try to help people get
out of their time shares so the diamond
uh group did the
sale to hilton did close
and
we're hearing that mike flasky and his
executive team all got put on the street
have you heard anything about that
i've not heard anything that i can share
on the air dave
[Laughter]
okay
i don't know i can't confirm it or deny
it i just thought i'd ask an expert i
think i just got my answer
oh that's fun
oh so if someone is is in a timeshare
what are their chances of doing an exit
successfully
well it depends uh on the uh
company from which you purchased your
timeshare it depends on whether you are
paid in full or whether you have one of
those horrible timeshare mortgages if
you have a timeshare mortgage it has
probably been sold
to an investment banker or to a wall
street type and that timeshare company
is going to hang on to that mortgage
debt that tenaciously and it's going to
be very
difficult for you to get out but there
there are methods i i'd like to
encourage people to look into charging
back on their credit cards if that's a
possibility
and you know hire a good attorney who
can negotiate for you or arbitrate for
you or file a lawsuit for you
so those are the ways to those are the
legal ways to try and get out of a time
chair but you're going to need the
assistance of a professional wow
yeah that does work
well scott thanks for your time and i
appreciate your expertise on this
subject and uh your your knowledge of
what's happening in the business out
there it's it's pretty crazy times lots
of uh
lots of people in your world are going
out of business have been run out of
business um and i'm glad you're sticking
in there and our prayers are with you
that you can turn the corner it's truly
a david and goliath's story george yeah
i mean it's shocking that
you know it's a bad financial investment
when it takes an attorney to get out
that's how you know this is a dangerous
game to play
yeah well here's what happens see like
if marriott finances your timeshare
they take that mortgage and sell it to a
hedge fund
the hedge fund gives marriott money
now the hedge fund is expecting to be
paid
on the mortgage they're really
somewhat innocent
of the fact that you got screwed over
here they just bought a piece of paper
that says you're supposed to pay them
right yeah and so then you go to
marriott and say uh you people committed
fraud
in the presentation
which we can prove
and marriott says you know what you got
us you got us we committed fraud and so
we're gonna let you out of your
timeshare but we can't help you with the
mortgage
because we don't own it anymore they've
washed their hands of it and so we got
your money cause we got our money from
the hedge fund but then the hedge fund's
sitting there holding the mortgage
that's what scott's talking about it's
dad gum near impossible to get out of
one if they've sold off the mortgage now
if marriott was still holding the
mortgage and you accused him all this
they said oh we'll let you out of
everything oh this is really bad we're
even gonna let you out of the mortgage
they have the more they own the mortgage
then they could let you go right yeah
but uh this is the kind of companies
you're dealing with here in these things
with windham and with diamond now hilton
uh owning diamond and uh westgate these
are the primary players at blue green
the big players in the business anton is
with us in new york city hi anton your
time share story
hey dave hey george how's everything um
so back in february of 2019
me and my girlfriend we were just
walking through the mall just minding
our business
and you know this
this well-dressed man came up to us and
um you know he was just calling us over
to him and he was just talking about
um you know vacation packages he never
used the word timeshare but basically
the one thing that he was selling was
that if we went to the meeting we
wouldn't have to purchase anything and
the only thing that we would have to do
is just sit through the sit through the
presentation and we can get like you
know two or three free nights stay or
something like that and we found that
appealing
especially since he really stressed the
fact that we wouldn't have to purchase
anything so we agreed we said okay
and um
the following month this is um out in
the poconos
we went out there to sit for the
presentation and
[Music]
they got us
um we thought we would only be there for
for maybe an hour or two
but they had us there for about four to
five hours
the guy that was selling us the
timeshare was going through he never
used the word timeshare he said it was a
vacation package and how you know this
is basically you know time shares of the
future
what is that what's the name of the
company
um club exploria oh wow so after a
couple hours why do you not walk out and
just give him the finger
i'm telling you dave
like after about three hours and
right before he proposed driving us
around the complex and showing us the
different you know homes and and rooms
that's when
you know
me and my girlfriend we started saying
to ourselves like okay this is
this is a little too much we're getting
a little uncomfortable but
man dave i'm telling you this guy would
not quit
he was
honestly the most
um the most pushy guy what did you
so they started high but eventually they
were able to bring it down you know
that's the tactics that they use but
they brought it down to around ten
thousand
um what's the end of the story did you
ever get out of it yes we did end up
getting out of it um we used timeshare
exit team
and they got you out
and they got us out yeah what did that
cost you
about four grand okay yeah so you pay
four grand to get out of a 10 grand
screw job but now you're free
now we're free yeah and you learn a
lesson man i'm so sorry wow well there
you go club exploria in the poconos a
guy in a suit in the mall that's all it
takes hey opry mills mall over here
they'll come up to you and start selling
you and they'll tell you dave ramsey's
got one oh my goodness i'm going to get
we're going to get a hidden camera and
go over there and you know like on my
baseball cap i'll go with you and this
will be and i'll show them then i'll
show them my driver's license and go you
know what dave ramsey doesn't have one
you little twerp
oh my goodness i would pay good money to
see this wouldn't that be fun
i'm getting excited about it let's take
a trip george we need something to do we
don't have enough to do with our lord
george campbell well that puts a crime
share i mean a time share hour in the
books thanks to james childs kelly
daniels we'll be back right here on the
ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality host of the entree
leadership podcast and a brand new
podcast on the ramsey networks called
the fine print a new episode of that
dropping this week on bitcoin if you're
interested jump into the fine print and
you can find out in lots of different
businesses and industries where the fine
print is stinging you oh yeah we talked
to a 17 year old kid who at 14 years old
mined some
ethereum coins and now can't remember
the password to his computer and is
locked out of 462 000
worth of aetherium
all from a computer password you know
that happened to me once
i was hoping i was like dave you ever
had a million dollars
i never lost a half a million dollars in
a computer other ways but i have found a
way to do it other stupid ways but wow
and mining those coins takes a lot of
electricity and a lot of technology yep
his parents walked in and said what are
you doing man is this 14 year old kid
with script on the computer he thought
there was he was hacking into the
mainframe well and the house is melting
down because there's the
electric meter outside is going
it can't handle it yeah yeah we hear
some we heard some crazy stories we
talked to a lot of people courtney
dykstra house was on there uh sharing
her story
about her uh crypto experience oh she
had a crypto yeah back when she was in
the news days and she would she was
glued to it it's addictive it's gamified
you're day trading right he's always
moving
worldwide unregulated and that's why
people get so pissed when you and i
bring it up because they're hooked on it
oh the dopamine starting to get this
yeah oh
i can't wait to listen to this it's
pretty great it's a wild ride open
phones this hour jennifer is in fort
lauderdale hi jennifer how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i um i own a home here in fort
lauderdale and i owe about 292 000 on it
um you know the realtors keep saying i
can sell for about 680.
the problem is i have uh 37 000 in debt
i have a bmw 20 and 17 000 and credit
card debt i've got a guy saying let's
just refinance the house put the you
know the 40 000 and the mortgage 348 and
i can save you 1200 a month and you can
pay an extra thousand dollars a month
and get it paid off in 10 years
problem is i make over 150 000 but it's
like you know i get commission checks so
it's always hard to budget correctly
you sell for a living don't you have a
shopping problem are you a salesperson
yeah yeah i thought so
me too
because you sound just like i used to
sound i tried to out earn my stupidity
for years
and then i tried to borrow my way out of
it
and you can't out earn it it catches up
doesn't it
you make a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year there's no reason for you
to have this debt except you've just
been a lazy and disorganized girl
i know
you don't need to refinance your home
i'm thinking about selling it because
moving to the west coast by my parents
and i'll make you know 400 000 buy
something cash let me help you with this
that's treating the symptom
not the problem
okay the problem is you're not handling
money well
i know
and i want you to do that for your sake
okay
hey i love you and i want you to win
but because i'm just like you that's why
i can read your mail i it's this exact
kind of stuff i did in my 20s that
caused me to be constantly broke
and um
so it it you know when you can get
organized you feel like you got a raise
yeah
so what's the total amount of debt here
57
and you make 150 000 a year
this is an easy math equation
well no i have the 292 000 on the house
and i have 37 000 for the car and the
credit card back and 20 000 on the
credit card that's 57 000 plus your
house right
i have over 17 000 in my bank right now
that i could okay
yeah so we got to get you on a really
really tight budget where every single
dollar does one thing
reduce debt i mean let's pretend that
you
you really really really sacrificed and
you lived on only a hundred thousand for
one year
crimea river
and you took the other 50 000 of your
income and you became debt free
in one year
hello
are you there she was so shocked
speechless is that was that sound was
that sound when you fell back on the
floor
and jennifer if you're following the
baby steps we teach you're not paying
off the house until baby steps house i
don't i'm not worried about the house
your house is in great shape you you got
a ton of equity in a great real estate
market now if you want to sell super
duper sell
but don't sell because you have a beamer
debt
don't refinance because you have a
beamer debt due to your disorganization
and never having applied yourself to
this let me ask you this do you set
goals on your sales
yeah
there you go well we're talking about
game plan tonight dave and i've been
digging into this goal stuff and once
you put the numbers down and on paper
just your consumer debt not the mortgage
this is baby step two we're talking
about you're gonna have a thousand
dollars in savings the rest the 16 we're
throwing at the debt and we're going to
follow the debt that's almost all the
credit card debt's gone yeah and chop up
the credit cards never use them again
get on a written budget and let's reach
over there and knock that rest of those
credit cards out and then knock that
beamer out
and this because what i'm telling you is
it becomes a goal when you set a goal in
sales you you say to yourself i gotta
kick it in gear i got a game on i got to
make it happen to hit this goal right
right but the only other problem is my
house i still need to put a new roof on
it and windows which is another 40 grand
you get what he means so if you want to
sell your house 25 sell your house
but don't sell your house because you're
in debt
yeah okay you make 150 000 a year and
we're telling you how you can get out of
debt and if you want to sell it sell it
i don't care
i'm not but but don't refinance it and
don't sell it because you're in debt
because you're going to go back in debt
because you never fixed why you went in
debt in the first place
and if you don't learn to save up the 40
000 to fix this house you're going to go
into debt for that too
and you know you have to stop this you
have to get the debt off the table and
say i'm sick and tired of constantly
paying the freaking bank i make too much
money to be this broke you have
seventeen thousand dollars to your name
and you make 150 grand
get disgusted girl
get mad
not at yourself in a bad way but get mad
enough to change and say that's it i've
had it the worm has turned i'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired whatever
it is you have to yell up into the
clouds and say god help me i need your
help this is killing me yeah
and she's got a great shovel dave so
this is not a she makes a lot of money
she's a smart girl she can cash flow the
home repairs she can get out of this
debt and she could do it all in a year
she if she gets to selling so 97 fixes
the house and makes her debt free oh
minus 16. so 81
does that making 150. so let's just say
we put 40 000 a year towards this
program in two years you're debt-free
and the house is repaired and that's
conservative
that's scary because you can't pay off
40 000 a year making 150 you are not
applying z principles
this is what we do here people
this is what we do you hang on girl
we're going to sign you up for financial
peace university if you will do what we
teach
you're going to be there in just a
matter of years if you don't
i predict you're still gonna be in the
mud
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage are jeff and anne to do
their debt-free scream hey guys how are
you hi dave we're great thanks
better than we deserve george and me
both so uh where uh where are you guys
from
we're from medina ohio near akron oh fun
and how much debt have you paid off
seventy four thousand three hundred
eighty one dollars i love it and how
long did this take you
it took us 18 long months okay
and your range of income during that
time uh it was from 53 800 to 63 000.
what do you guys do for a living
we're we're both retired okay uh
working part-time okay both of us yeah
not a bad income so you've got some
retirement income coming in yes yes all
right what kind of debt was the 74 000
you're going to love this one
timeshare
oh
no did we plan this the whole scene
no
there was
some credit card debt a time share loan
uh an equity loan on the home and
uh
a car loan a car uh
so do you still have the first mortgage
on the home or does that mean the homes
paid off too no we still have the first
mortgage gotcha okay wow so how long you
guys been married
almost 50 almost 50 years january
january congratulations thank you that
is so awesome so after that many years
of marriage what happened 18 months ago
that set you on fire and said we got to
get out of debt
we signed up for
a financial peace class at our church oh
wow we had been thinking about it for a
couple of years but we were normally
vacationing during the time when it was
offered
and
we decided
but we almost didn't do it
because we had to go to our timeshare in
florida
at that time this is too ironic and i
know i just and um
someone from church because we're older
it seemed like most people doing this
were younger and she said oh they're
they were older too she said let's do it
do it with us
so okay we'll do it with you
and uh then we were going to miss a
couple of the classes
oh no now what do we do well she said
amanda who amanda sherrod who is our
amanda and jason are
our cheerleaders cheerleaders
taught the class uh she says oh you can
watch it
just
you know pull up your laptop and watch
it while you're on vacation so we did oh
wow and uh so we had no excuses
and it just the timing was
god very much god of the whole thing
just everything way it worked
i you know when somebody's been married
for 10 minutes
and they say we're going to dive in and
we're going to go crazy and we're going
to pay off
74 000 in 18 months
that's impressive when you have been
married almost 50 years
and you decide to do this
that's impressive yeah it's harder to
break all those habits that you've built
i mean that that the change in mindset
what in the world this is so intriguing
you guys are amazing okay thanks
so you said 18 long months did you mean
that
yes it was a struggle
particularly for me i didn't want to cut
up the credit cards i didn't want to
really do the program at all and what
made you guys decide to do it
uh
it was working for oh amanda and her
husband for sure and uh
we needed to do something we didn't want
to leave um we don't as far as a legacy
we didn't want our children to be have a
debt have our debt and while we're when
we're gone we want to be
free and clear yeah and um
we had been working on on our own just
trying to
nickel and dime it a little bit here and
there and we weren't really making any
progress
we needed to take that next step so the
frustration of that said okay i'm going
to try this weird guest system
we're gonna go in and our friends are
doing and it's working so i'm gonna go
in and and that's what turned the corner
for you jeff yeah yeah that because i
didn't want to do it at first you said
and that's me that's how i would be i'm
like you jeff that's very cool it's very
impressive
wow so part of it was
a lot a lot of it was the time share we
ended up talking to the timeshare exit
people
and they told us we should go directly
to diamond
to be able to get out of it and so
that's what we ended up doing so you
didn't you didn't do you didn't actually
use time share exit instead you went
straight to diamond they told us to go
on a diamond and how much trouble was
that to get out
quite a bit it took months and we had we
had to pay a thousand dollars every time
you sign up for more points that's a
deed
so we had three deeds
uh so it was a thousand dollars for each
of those
and then we had to get all of our
maintenance paid for of course
and the maintenance oh my goodness
it went from it went from about four
hundred dollars when we first got in and
it was about eighteen hundred dollars a
year yeah at the end yeah we had really
three mortgages
i mean because we had our equity loan we
were which had the highest interest rate
you could think of
and then our regular mortgage and the
equity loan so we consider those three
more mortgages
and now we're down to one wow and we
we redid our mortgage um it was
30 years
it's now 15 years
um and what two point something percent
i forget
how does it feel
amazing wonderful like the big burdens
lifted off our shoulders worth the 18
months are tough absolutely yeah
okay
so i gotta know i'm gonna be completely
inappropriate how old are you guys
72
i'm 75 and i'm 70. 70. okay
so you robbed the cradle 50 years ago
old 25 year old boy married a 20 year
old girl i love it that's awesome you
guys are amazing i'm so proud of you
thanks i'm so proud to know you very
very well done and i'm honored that we
had a little bit to do in your wonderful
story
the number of people that are married 50
years is almost none to start with these
days and then on top of that uh you guys
have decided late in life to just try a
new chapter yeah and that's very very
impressive most people get stuck in
their ways and don't do it
you guys are very neat people and we
might come back we would like to come
back when we get our mortgage paid off i
would love to have you and have a total
one total debt kelly will uh kelly will
make you move you right to the front of
the debt stream line fast pass that
stream line that'll happen yeah you guys
are amazing i'm so proud of you we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure without a doubt
and uh then we'll give you a copy of the
total money makeover to give away to
somebody and maybe get them started
because a friend got you started in
financial peace university that's how
this all happened can we mention our
family sure we have three children
grandchildren and 10 grandchildren wow
some of them are watching so
that's fine
life is good if i don't know how great
grandbabies are going to be out have
been nicer to their parents
[Laughter]
you guys are fun well done well done
well done all right jeff and ann from
akron ohio 74 000 paid off in 18 months
making 53-63 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three three two
one where's
[Music]
[Applause]
don't tell me it's too late 75 years old
and they decided don't tell me it's too
late it's not too late not too late at
all and it's not too late for you guys
to sign up and join us for game plan
tonight you can execute a game plan and
do just what they did exactly i'm going
to be sharing about how to set the right
goals and actually see success and i
share my own stories of failures and the
stuff i've learned that have helped me
accomplish my financial goals and it's a
lot of the stuff that we're hearing in
these dead free screams yeah they had a
big why you and your wife are getting
ready to pay off your house oh yeah just
around the corner up here just a few
months along the way and you keep asking
for raise i know what it's for i'm
kidding it's for a good reason dave just
know that
you guys man it's incredible so here's
the deal 7 p.m tonight central time we
have a free live stream with number one
best-selling author christy wright which
is a ramsey personality george camel
ramsey personality sitting here to my
right and of course me and we're gonna
be talking about goal setting about the
information from her book take back your
time and certainly about laying out a
financial money game plan it's all free
text game plan to 33 789 and join 20 000
of your closest friends online game plan
to 33789
all one word game plan to 33 789 seven
o'clock tonight it's a free live stream
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of
the
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
lou and brittany are with us hey guys
how are you doing fantastic good good so
good to have you guys so where do you
live we live in newpreg minnesota which
is near it is an hour south of the twin
cities okay all right the minneapolis
area then okay cool and uh how much debt
have you guys paid off 49 000 16.66
way to go and how long did that take 13
months good for you
and your range of income during that
time 27 000 to 90
wow
nice jump in 13 months what do you do
for a living what happened to the income
um so i am a media specialist for two
different companies for calvary church
and for my father's company
and i'm a truck driver so i try semi
trucks locally so i deliver to
local stores
and restaurants okay what'd you guys do
to triple your income um that's exactly
what we did
he took a truck driving job yeah he
changed over um he wasn't manufacturing
and then um
through a series of events he ended up
in truck driving i love it nice race
well it worked out yeah so uh what kind
of debt was the 49 thousand we had a
little bit of everything we had credit
cards we had medical bills we had two
car loans we had student loans we had
uh house
renovation projects so
wow
very good you guys very good
so what happened 13 months ago that got
you on this journey
well um lou actually lost his job
because of coven
and so then we were down to just my
income which is why it was so low at the
beginning
and it was like oh no we've already
overdrafted in our account prior to him
losing his job i'm like how are we going
to survive
now and i had just read your financial
piece book my parents had given it to me
from like an old class they had taken
and so i had read it in february and
then april hit and that's when he lost
his job and so it was like we have to do
something so i convinced him hey there's
a free trial online let's go watch the
fpu classes
and so we watched them together within a
week
yeah we just
watched it all the way because i mean
what is he going to do
financial feature you can binge tiger
king choose wisely all right yep and so
that's what got us on the journey wow
wow good for you good for you and you
went into gear i mean hardcore
yeah he uh took on three jobs so it's
like he went from having no job to
having three jobs he was working
manufacturing for 10 hours and then he
would go to a pizza delivery place for
another five hours at night and then on
the weekends he was doing uh truck
driving to ease into the full-time truck
driving that he is now yeah wow
way to go guys
excellent excellent work i'm so proud of
you guys what do you tell people the key
to getting out of that is well for me
definitely the budgets
um i think that
just having a plan and having it on
paper or in an app we love the
everydollar app um that is just huge you
can't keep track of it in your head i
thought i could you can't you overdraft
that's how you overdraft you tried to
budget in your head
it's impressive so how old are you two
um we're both 26 but he's turning 27 on
thursday so
all right congratulations happy birthday
thank you yeah well done you guys have
any cheerleaders along the way
yes so we have my family here with me
they were huge cheerleaders for us
and then our church family was really
big and was always asking us well how
far are you how close are you and so
they were really helpful as well you got
into so much you got the t-shirts
printed and everything yeah we got to
tell people what is honestly a little
bit like no one else with a gazelle on
it his says and then hers is warning may
start talking about budgets at any time
i love that
[Laughter]
that's spreading the loss you went from
being all in your head and now you're
just talking about it constantly i love
that yeah it moved slightly yeah and we
brought a we brought a third one um
because we had an announcement to make
[Laughter]
we are pregnant with our first child
congratulations
if you're listening let me tell you
what's happening it's the most adorable
baby shirt and it says i'm in the
debt-free club i love it
well congratulations so does everybody
know already back home well now they
know
this was it this is the official
announcement
what better way they've got a great
platform to share the news on exactly
now
yeah they got to watch your debt free
screw this is great you guys
wow
well congratulations this is what a
special year this has been yes their
whole lives are changed
so proud of you for taking control and
both of you neither one of you afraid of
hard work you're willing to put in the
hours to get it done and and uh once you
take control of this you know you can
take control of a lot of things
so very very very well done
all right we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because obviously you're
having a new legacy that's awesomeness
very very cool next chapter in your
story is um baby steps millionaires
without a doubt you guys are fun very
well done and we got to copy the total
money makeover for you to give away to
someone since you can't stop talking
about budgeting you can give them a copy
of the book right yeah probably hand it
out and go read this yeah that'll work
very very cool all right lou and britney
and baby from minneapolis
49 000 paid off in 13 months making 27
to 90. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two
one
we're pregnant and dead
[Applause]
wow that was fun what timing oh
that is fabulous you can't beat that
can't beat a baby announcement and the
debt-free announcement all at once yeah
it's not very very very cool
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from tony in new jersey i know
dave teaches about investing in the four
mutual fund categories through a 401k or
ira but i prefer investing in single
stocks on my own i deposit money
regularly in my robinhood account and it
seems to be doing pretty well what's the
downside to this type of investing as
long as i'm contributing from every
paycheck
this one we're exploring on the fine
print dave oh we're yeah this is going
to be a whole episode on diy investing
on robin hood a lot of stuff in the news
about robin hood and uh this is an area
where you know people feel like they're
they can be tricky they go well you know
i get dave's stuff it's old school it's
it's a little boring it's a tortoise
but dave i've made some good money off
some single stocks this year tesla's
been doing great i'm throwing some money
into tesla and the problem is uh until
you touch the hot stove you feel like
you know what you're doing cooking in
the kitchen
and so my worry for tony is that if you
want to mess with single stocks after
you've done the 15 retirement this is
fun money for you and this is a real
small percentage of your portfolio
that's fine but don't put your all of
your eggs in this single stock basket
that frightens me yeah
the bible says spread your portions to
seven yes to eight for disaster may come
upon the land
that's a biblical version of
diversification
leaving all your eggs in one basket some
idiot
on wall street is twirling the basket
and you're betting everything on that
one idiot
that makes you
not smart
diversification lowers risk and
increases rates of return over a long
period of time it's a standard
portfolio management process that has
been used in financial planning for
decades and it outperforms the single
stock investor
not maybe not on the short term but
single stock investors are a lot like
fishermen all they talk about was the
time they caught a boatload they never
talk about the time they went out there
and lost everything
they never talk about the time that it
went through the floor and then
everything got messed up because some
media was playing margin on them and so
you you tony you're asking for it you're
playing russian roulette with your money
you're asking for it and you're going to
get your head taken off son
the market's going to correct your
little butt
and it's just a matter of when and then
you're gonna have an ouchy moment and
you're gonna know what george and i are
talking about
diversification lowers risk spreading
your money across many many investments
like in a mutual fund versus being in
single stocks you are asking for trouble
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you are here wynn is with us in
houston texas hi welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for taking my call how
are you better than i deserve how can we
help
awesome hi um i'm a 25 year old single
guy
i grew up in texas went to college got a
master's in accounting
and then after college i got a great job
and moved to new york city for about a
year
when coveted hit and i was a part of
that group that blessing in disguise
kind of escape the city and migrate it
back to my parents where i've been
saving and working remotely um and just
saving really
and so i don't have a lot of expenses
and i've
put up about 45 000 in my 401k
um in addition to
kind of 23 000 just sitting in a bank
account
um and i'm looking to move back and so
my question is
um what do i do with that extra money is
it worth buying a rental property and
somewhere like houston where i can
um maybe one day move back and i can be
making a little bit of rental income on
the side or should i just park it in a
ira or mutual fund while i pay for rent
in new york because i can't afford real
estate in new york so you're going to be
renting in new york and you're wondering
should i buy some property for fun as a
rental in texas with this uh money use
it as a down payment
and then maybe move back into that
property one day in five ten years hmm
well
you may need a little more than that i
don't know what the i mean you're in the
houston area
correct
yeah i mean you're a young guy and i
feel like you're not sure where life's
gonna take you i don't think rental
property is a bad idea and you may turn
that into a primary residence one day
but i just think there's a lot of life
ahead of you and i don't know that
you know this is where you want to plant
it right now with that chunk of change
yeah two problems one is you're getting
ready to go into debt on the rental
property and two um it's gonna be long
distance rental so if i'm in your shoes
i'm not doing it for those two reasons
i'm just gonna rent in new york for a
little while and pile up cash continue
to pile up cash until you figure out
what your long-term game plan is somehow
i don't think you're in new york city
for 25 years
yeah i don't do that yeah and when you
come back to houston or back to wherever
you choose to come quote back to texas
tennessee whatever it is
that is when you would buy in that
market and by then you'd have a really
really good pile of cash you might even
pay cash for your first house i love
that if you were if you did that that's
a possibility but no i would not own
long distance rental property and i
would not go in debt to do it
uh two reasons to stay away from that
sounds kind of cool sounds kind of fun
uh until the renter doesn't pay
all right zachary is in atlanta hi
zachary how are you
better better than i can
um so i have um
a couple things going on uh first i've
been i've been on
your plan for on the ramsey plan for for
quite a while i've gotten out of debt uh
i think twice been totaling over 28 000
dollars total
um that was all due to a workers comp
lump sum paying it off so i didn't
really like learning the lesson you know
um so
right now i'm in atlanta and i'm an
electrician um i do that and because
covid stuff it's been back and forth on
how much i'm making and things like that
because they're raising prices and all
that i'm also a youth pastor
um and i just it's basically
um
just on sundays and stuff like that
meeting with the youth and the lord's
been really good there
so i have about eight thousand dollars
left in this debt um and this grouping i
was at 18 a few months ago and then i
um sold the truck
and that was hard to do but i sold it
and we got about 8k left
we got a baby on the way
and i um
i'm having an issue getting full going
on the ramsey way
because i didn't learn the lesson the
first time
um
and i think my issue is one i mean i
know i need to i'm cutting the eating
out actually brought my lunch today
thanks to my wife um my biggest issue
that i'm having is with the envelope
system i'm not sure how to budget with
envelopes with money that i don't
already have in cash yet
and i'm kind of struggling with that
along with the i know i need to stop
eating out
i just want to get some advice on that
well let's just use uh a grocery store
envelope as an example
okay
when you go to the grocery store if
you're not borrowing money to buy the
groceries
you're either hitting your debit card
and taking out of your checking account
or you're taking out of your groceries
envelope
agreed yeah the cash yeah yeah so what
would be the wrong with taking the money
out of your checking account and put it
in cash in the grocery envelope
because it's him there would be an issue
with that it's in there well no so
here's yeah so at the end of the month
um i get paid bi-weekly and so at the
end of the month i have or the first of
the month have rent come in so all the
money i've saved up at the first of the
month okay i'm like all right so i'm
let's say the 30th of september we're
going to sit down and do our budget be
my
and we're going to want to put cash in
there well i'm not going to have any
cash to put in any of the oven then
you're not going to have money to buy
groceries in your checking account
until the church pays me on the fourth
of every month like they've been doing
and then
so my point is your system wait a minute
stop you're not going to buy groceries
for four days out of your checking
account is what you're saying
yeah we had planned uh the two weeks
prior to get stuff before um well how
did you i mean that way the envelope is
not the problem the problem is you
didn't plan to have money for groceries
yeah if you've got money for groceries
in your checking account there's nothing
stopping you from keeping it out and
putting it in the grocery envelope
okay i'm just processing okay
you see what i'm saying
you can't write a check or use your
debit card at the grocery store unless
there's money in your account agreed
yeah and if there's money in your
account you could take that exact same
amount out of your account and put it in
cash into an envelope set of groceries
on it couldn't you
yeah okay so you're not short of cash
unless you're short of cash
the envelopes don't change the equation
yeah
it's just when the just i guess it's
just when we're sitting down doing it on
the 30th i don't have any of the cash to
put in for the beginning of the month
till the 4th or then how are you buying
groceries between the first and the
fourth
now
i would have bought it a week or two
prior ta-da
so am i do you fill the envelope when
the next check comes in on the fourth
yeah because that's the way you're doing
it now
the only difference is you're writing it
out your checking account or something
no i'm i'm hearing it so whatever that
next check is after the fourth that
needs to fund you through the next time
you get a paycheck so you can divide it
up if you want we have been doing but
go ahead but you're having issues with
with doing it that way
uh dividing it up yeah that's the best
way to say that yeah yeah just divide it
by two if you're getting two checks a
month and your grocery bill's 200 bucks
you can put 100 in on one check and 100
on the other if that gets you through
all right it's not going to be that'd be
more than that but the the
it's every two weeks so you've got to
look at the calendar
yeah cause you don't get checks on the
1st and the 15th you get a check on
every month on the 4th for your youth
pastoring and then you get a check every
two weeks so some weeks
twice a year you get three checks in a
month
that's true yeah because you have the
magic money when you get paid every two
weeks yeah
and so two times a year december this
year exactly
exactly so that that's the point and um
so what you gotta do is you sit down you
look at the calendar and you say this
month the month of september i'm going
to get or the month of october now
coming up i'm going to get a check on x
and y
and i'm going to get a check on the
fourth and then you allocate each one of
those checks across the things and oh by
the way the very most important category
of all is food
yeah the four corners of i've heard you
say before
exactly
exactly um and i had one more other
thing if i have a time for it
the uh so the wife is pregnant and it's
really hard to say no to a pregnant
woman who's hungry so do i need to set
us a separate budget for that to come
out of or do i just say look baby we're
just gonna have to suck it up uh the
pregnant woman that's hungry has to say
no to herself because she's building a
life for her child
it's not your job to be her daddy
she looks in the mirror and says it's
good for my family for us to be on a
budget and stick to that budget and has
to agree to the budget you don't tell
her what the budget is the two of you
together agree to the budget and then
she will be saying no to herself because
she's like a grown-up woman and stuff
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
joining me at the top of the hour here
two ramsey personalities george campbell
and number one best-selling author
christy wright the two of them will be
with us tonight
uh with me tonight we will be doing the
three musketeers here
i'm going to be doing a live stream
tonight so far about 20 000 of you have
signed up so my guess is it'll be
somewhere north of 30 000 by the time we
get there this evening
and uh looking forward to it it's a free
live stream at 7 00 p.m tonight christy
wright george campbell me it's called
game plan and we're going to be helping
you put together a game plan if you'd
like to join us this evening text game
plan to 33 789 text
this is going to be gamepl christy yeah
it's huge because i love that we're
hitting on topics that affect every
aspect of our audience's life from money
goals and time these are things that
affect everything and we're going to
show them step by step how they can get
it together and uh and man i love that
about our company we're just talking
about this monday at staff meeting we
give
information and instruction and also
inspiration you're gonna need both so
i'm super excited
absolutely and i get to uh to go up
first and talk about how to not only set
goals but see results and i share my
stories of failure and i've had my fair
share when it comes to goals and i've
learned so much from dave from christy
from entre leadership and i'm just i'm
just lucky to be there i mean among you
guys this is squad goals that's what we
call it on social media squad goals so
to share the stage with you guys and
really tell people here's how you make a
goal here's how you actually stick with
it here's how you create a vision for
your life for your money and christy you
talking about balance and priorities and
doing the right things and dave really
laying out the game plan that has worked
for millions of people i'm just pumped
yeah that's gonna be good and big
announcement drum roll please drum roll
yeah here we go take back your time
debuted at number one it's a number one
best-selling book christy's second
number one last week and uh we just got
word over the weekend actually that uh
you'll see it on the bestseller list
like for instance the wall street
journal is the number one publishers
weekly will be a number one and so on uh
take back your time all about getting
control of your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance uh
christy yet another number one
congratulations thank you thank you so
much team effort but thank you thank you
it's so exciting yeah the team at ramsey
works really really hard on book
launches and the marketing yep and the
whole process we put into this is very
dialed in it's very specific and uh we
also the personalities work hard yeah
because you have done what 200 media
hits in the past two weeks yes i think
close to that it's just it's just under
200 was the report i saw yes yeah you've
been on everything yep and so talking
about it and that's you know your hard
work you're working putting this
together but most importantly it's a
book that uh life balance is about doing
the right things at the right time and
you get to decide what is right that's
powerful that's right and it's amazing
too because it is setting people free
i'm getting feedback on social media
they're saying again and again wow this
is not just another time management book
this is not just a productivity book i
feel one one woman wrote in i didn't
just get my time back i got my power
back and i thought okay let's send that
to the marketing team send that out on
the website that is true that's true
that's the essence of it yeah well it is
when you've got a control over your
money you got control over your time
your life is different that's right
that's right when you feel
pushed to the edge
i mean i'm in about a two-week period
right now of just
every little every 15 minutes or
something going on in my stinking
schedule it's my fault i did it
but uh but it's just
busy just a busy season and you just
don't have much peace when you don't
give yourself some margin and uh you
know
i'm fine with it because i know it's for
a short period of time and i'm not
complaining but the point is when you've
got control of your time and you have
control of your money it gives you
margin and it gives you a sense of power
yeah she said yeah and a sense of peace
yeah and i love that we talk about
living on less than you make but how
many people do that with their time no
one has that kind of margin that's right
and so i love that we talked about this
on the entree leadership podcast christy
for for leaders but i love this doesn't
apply to just business it doesn't apply
to just moms it applies to every human
being who has anything going on and i
felt this i i needed the content more
than a lot of people because we run hard
right all three of us we just go go go
go go and if we're not careful we have
that feeling of being out of balance and
out of control and the steps that you
lay out are so crystal clear this isn't
fluff isn't feelings this is stuff that
you have lived out and you have dreamed
up for a decade now well thank you and
it's interesting too because dave i
remember years ago when you did a
session for our company on one of our
core values of family being a core value
and the way that you described balance
at that time this was i mean a million
years ago the old building
just keep saying a million i've told you
at least 10 million times not to
exaggerate
it's not lovely i wonder where she gets
it from it's my love language hey
but you would say over the cour you
might have a season of hustle a season
of rest a season of this that the other
but over the course of your life
you feel balance
overall and i think that's a good
reminder for someone that's in a season
of hustle in a season of getting out of
debt in a season of your two week you
know a sprint here that's what's right
right now now if you spent a decade like
that you would burn out and be exhausted
but but anyone when we look at hey this
is what's right in the season or in the
summer hey we're taking fridays off
going on vacation that's what's right
right now it just gives you that
permission to do the right things at the
right time and not feel guilty when
you're super busy and also not feel
guilty when you put your feet up on
vacation because there's a i love
ecclesiastes there's a time for
everything and so i want to remind
people of that and give them permission
to focus on what's right for them
number one number one national
bestseller as of this week it launched
last week and so we're just getting the
information in on take back your time
the guilt free guide to life balance
the author of that ramsey personality
christie wright will be speaking tonight
at 7 pm on this subject take back your
time the guilt-free guide to life
balance george campbell will be talking
with you tonight on the subject of goals
hitting them and setting them and uh
these things all weave together to put
together a game plan and i'll be
speaking to you about some things you
can do to get control of your money and
you know i'm fairly predictable on that
you've done it a time or two
it's uh it wasn't hard to put the talk
together
but the uh uh so you won't be shocked
there won't be a new revelation from
dave on monday
but uh you know if you haven't if you
haven't experienced this is a great
thing to do sit down with your spouse
sit down with your friends and uh watch
this live stream it is completely free
at 7 00 p.m
this evening game plan you need a game
plan you don't want a game without a
game plan yeah at least the big games
you don't you can wander in and with
sheer talent knock it out sometimes but
if you're going to win the super bowl
you go in with a game plan if you're
going to win the national championship
you're going to go in with a game plan
and that's what we're going to teach you
tonight is give you a game plan at all
of this it's completely free a free live
stream at 7 pm tonight how do you
register you type one word game plan no
spaces all one word to 33 789
game plan to 33789
congratulations again christy we're all
so proud of you thank you thank you very
much very well done good stuff another
number one two for her
boom
drop the mic
it's done
yes i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five welcome
to the ramsey show brent is with us
brent's in akron ohio hi brent welcome
to the show
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up uh
my wife and i
were
in the process of getting ready to build
a house
last fall
before all the
pandemonium hit
and
as we were finalizing our loan and stuff
the builder came back and said that the
prices had gone up to the point where
our build was going to be
50 percent more than what we had planned
so we we mixed the build for last year
and don't blame you we are
we are trying to decide
if when the right time is to build
if we should if we should just trudge
ahead
or
do we need to wait for the economy to
settle down or
i mean is it going to settle down it's
going to settle down
some of the artificial jump in the
real estate and the cost of construction
was driven by supply chain interruptions
and so
people were not working in the factories
and they were not sending as a result
finished goods
that are required to build a home
for instance lumber
and there was a shortage of lumber so
lumber spiked
up
and it is an artificial spike because
what will happen is they the factories
will get caught up
and then when the supply starts to equal
the demand a little closer then the
prices will come back down to more
reasonable
prices now that it's not necessarily
going to happen with real estate real
estate shot up but it didn't shoot and
it shot up just because there's a frenzy
in the market we're not necessarily
going to see a drop in prices but we
will see the frenzy dissipate
over time and so i agree with you this
is a horrible time to build a house um i
mean i've got some friends that are
building and it's just uh they're
getting increases after increases after
increases in their stuff
i've got a couple construction projects
going right now and they're hammering us
on for instance steel i just got a nice
big bill on steel the other day
and we're building a conference center
even putting in the uh the sound system
in the conference center i'm i don't
need it for a year and i think we're
probably going to go ahead and order it
this month
because they're anticipating increases
in prices but it's artificial because
it's just due to shortages of the
components
and uh so i i think probably building a
year from now or two years from now
you're going to see a whole different
world to build a house in than you're
seeing today that's my guess but you
know that may be worth what you paid for
it brother yeah we recently uh covered
this topic on the fine print on the
housing gold rush so brent go listen to
that it may give you some encouragement
we talked to brian biffini and he gave
us some great data on what's going on in
the housing market and it's encouraging
but like you're saying dave you're not
going to see a price uh the price just
shoot way down what we will see is
things will slow down to where it's not
frenzied and it's not all chaos and you
know bids 50 higher so i think being
patient is wise and the thing with the
housing market is you do it when you're
financially ready so if you follow the
parameters that we teach 15-year fixed
rate quarter of the take-home pay you'll
be in good shape but i don't want you to
wait five years because you're scared of
what the market may or may not do yeah
as far as overall purchase of real
estate i completely agree again
lumber
copper
those are commodities and they come and
go on pricing
and um i really do believe there's a
artificial height in some of those
things right now that is going to
correct down which is going to change
the price of new housing so your
builder's not going to come in and go oh
you're going to anticipate a 50 increase
now i'll just wait until that's not
there
because i really don't believe that's
going to continue yeah uh but i do think
real estate's going to continue to be a
good investment long term
so what's the you know what's the
timeline the horizon i don't know how
long does it take these supply chain
wrinkles
to get um
ironed out and that's really what it
amounts to
may is with us may is in portland oregon
hi may welcome the ramsay show
hello guys thanks for taking my call
sure um
so i am 20 years old as well as my
boyfriend and we have no debt
we have two vehicles that we paid cash
for and we are currently living at his
parents house
we also have our emergency fund done and
our four months emergency fund for the
bills that we do have
and we are currently saving for either
house or down payment we are wanting to
get married and we also want a bigger
truck i have horses and
we need a bigger truck to um pull the
horse trailer and whatnot so we are just
wondering what to do next because all of
them kind of are
a large amount of money and we can't buy
a house with no credit
and so we're kind of just kind of lost
in life
so your next goal you said is to get
married
yeah we want to get married and we are
living at his parents house so we were
wanting to get a house we wouldn't like
to rent just because we
feel it's kind of a waste of money we
want to invest in a house
so based on what you're saying it sounds
like you guys have already combined
finances what's going on there
um we actually do not combine finances
sorry that was confusing so you have
separate emergency funds and separate
accounts and separate savings and all
that
yes we do okay
well for sure i paid cash with my
vehicle he's paid cash with his vehicle
he has his four-month savings i have my
four-month saving we both have our
emergency fund
but he's just at work so i'm kind of
calling for both of us and
the future kind of involves both of our
incomes if we were to get married so
so well
number one let me tell you do not buy a
house
with someone you're not married to
under any circumstances
because you're gonna get yourself into a
mess
uh if this doesn't work out
the breakup is harder to do than a
divorce is
and um you know it's very difficult to
get out because you know he just decides
to leave you got the house it's in your
name it's in his name and or you want to
leave you can leave because you've got a
house
and a mortgage and you're stuck in the
thing so do not buy a house prior to
marriage
under any circumstances and don't buy
any asset of any kind or combine
accounts prior to marriage just because
of that so let me tell you what i what
i've run into 30 years of doing this may
this is why okay there's all these worst
case scenarios but there's also stuff
that's not quite this ugly but here's an
extreme one okay a couple gets engaged
they go buy a house together he gets
killed in a car wreck
now she owns a house with his mother
because he didn't have a will
you see how messy this gets
this is a myth
however if you were married now she owns
a house
instantly changes
if you're married you're going to get
the house
and you know without a will even and so
with a will you know it's a problem so i
i would tell you you're 20 years old you
got plenty of time to buy a house
you guys get married go get you a rental
property pay or go get you a place to
rent inexpensive pile up cash get the
truck pay cash for it uh do some stuff
start piling up cash for a good down
payment if it takes you two or three
years you're 23 years old you buy a
house you're not going to die
well i guess he has one because it's
more of his goal to get the truck but
he has like a checklist of a thousand
dollars on a line and every time he gets
a thousand he puts it away okay so we
are our goal is to put you know or his
goal is to pay cash for his truck that
would be the only way he should buy one
yeah that's yep we've been listening to
you for quite a while and we paid cash
for both four vehicles and they're both
nice so that was kind of
rewarding my kids are ten my youngest is
10 years older than you all right
so here's what i would tell you if you
were if you were my kid
i would say go get married tomorrow and
go get you a rental property by the end
of the week
move in a rental and start your life
quit trying to play house under daddy's
roof
it's a it's a mess
that's what i would tell you but you
called the old guy and asked him and
you're going to get the old guy dad joke
right so i'm sorry but that's dave's a
boomer yeah dadgum right i
actually am technically a boomer so if
boomer uh the baby boomers are an actual
demographic like millennials it's like
you're a millennial it's like you're
calling somebody a name or something
he's a boomer i feel like only you can
call yourself old david it's a term of
derision yeah yeah but i'm
hey i'm comfortable with it i like it i
like it
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage rudy and tracy
are with us hey guys hi dave hi dave
how's it going better than i deserve
welcome good to have you guys thank you
very much where do you live
uh goodyear arizona phoenix phoenix area
okay good market love that area well
welcome guys good to have you and you're
up here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off 68 000 plus all
right and how long did that take 19
months whoa
and your range of income during that
time it was between 105 105 and 115.
cool what do you all do for a living i
work at a warehouse
food distribution center
and uh and i work for our local church
awesome very cool good for you guys
excellent so what kind of debt was the
68 000
uh the majority of it was uh solar
panels and a car and then the rest was
medical and consumer debt okay how long
y'all been married
uh we just had our anniversary on the
22nd of this month and it was
this was our 20-year anniversary we got
married twice okay never divorced just
married twice that'll work i'll take it
but i i i have no idea what we're doing
here but yeah that's that's that's
yeah i'm so confused but all right so
what happened 19 months ago or so that
put you guys on to our stuff and you
said we're getting out of debt tell me
about it
well it was actually myself i was doing
some con i was doing some retail therapy
while rudy was working out of town uh-oh
heard a
a single mom who paid off seventy
thousand dollars in debt in one year
and was not only inspired but i was
convicted
we were two incomes and you know
were we doing the best we actually could
be doing
and i i really when we gathered all the
numbers it was shocking
and um it was that point that i said you
know we we need to do something better
and our at our church they had a class
we joined it
and uh the rest is history
awesome
way to go guys congratulations so it
worked out so where did you hear that
about this single mom
it was a i had the tv on going on in the
background as i was getting ready to go
to work
and it was a morning show
and that they kind of spotlighted and
from there i was just like i i always
knew that we were
i thought we were good at you know
budgeting
i was good at managing debt and not
overextending and had a really
um false sense of security um so we want
the real thing dave
george that's what's dropping mike's
over here yeah what's happening that
that's uh that's good stuff yeah and i
love the debt-free scream going from
inspirational to convicting that's
powerful to think about it in that way
you guys really had a big mental shift
because you had a lot of mess going on i
mean how much were these solar panels
i'm just curious it was over 20 000 wow
for 20 years and we had leased a car
prior that we were upside down in so we
tacked on an additional six thousand
dollars to a car loan to get you know
get it get out of the lease
so you're and you're saying i was really
good at managing all the debt but we
weren't making any progress no not good
at managing money but i was good at
managing debt
that's half of america right there or
more i mean that that's a that's a real
insight that's well said and well
observed
good job and so uh
poor rudy comes home
and you've had this whole experience and
and you said we're going to this class
over the church what'd rudy say
i was on board i mean
um i'm pretty much you know willing to
try anything it's
i'm not like uh i don't have that macho
machismo i'm like
it made sense i'm like let's do it yeah
you're not hard to get along with like
me yeah okay all right because i would
have argued
just for the fun of it i think just for
the argument points george you're you're
like him i'm more like him yeah well
if it makes whitney happy i'm happy to
do it yeah yeah
well i generally say that but i might
argue about it a little bit first yeah
good for you guys well the silver lining
and all that dave is we were able to um
through the pandemic our son moved back
home and finished school um college
online and you always kind of think as a
parent have i departed all uh you know
we we could have and this is the one
topic that
was really um a conversation we need to
have and he was um able to witness
the progress in real time and be open to
understanding
hey we want you to you know have the
best do do well in life
here's how you do it and um don't wait
at your our age yes yeah we i love your
legacy videos it makes me cry every time
but
that was what we really strongly wanted
to do was change our family tree
and uh leave a lasting legacy yeah
absolutely powerful that's very cool so
he bought in too yes he's doing quite
well for himself he he moved in to
washington to work and i miss him
terribly but i know he's gonna do well
in life yeah well because he had some
good parents
yeah you guys did a good job i'm proud
of you very cool very cool okay now that
you've done it you're debt free you pay
off 68 000 in 19 months
tell people what the secret to getting
out of debt is
well for us budget yeah budgeting and
getting reconnected with your finances
we we were so disconnected that we
didn't know the numbers that were coming
in and going out
and it's
it was nerve-wracking when we were doing
everything in cash envelopes and you
know pulling out cash at the grocery
store i would literally get so nervous
you know that i'm holding up the line
i i noticed that and so
i don't know
your money that's a good phrase
physically reading phrases i'm writing
all this down i'm taking those great
but i i like that because what you know
we each get our weekly
you know budget and when it runs out
there's it runs out there's not no
talent no lying on that number
and we also led a couple fpu classes at
our church so that kind of helps us stay
plugged in yeah and stays us to
to to be accountable that's a big deal
there's something about teaching the
class versus going through it that uh
makes you you can't
you can't be a hypocrite when you're
teaching it you can't do ish it doesn't
work you got to do it full on right yeah
so what's the name of your church grace
walk community church wonderful very
cool well they're obviously doing a
great job
obviously doing a great job so well done
you guys i'm proud of you excellent
excellent
excellent
good stuff
all right well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey the book for you that
i'll sign at the break for you and a
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give away to somebody and get their
journey started you never know if you're
going gonna be like that uh single mom
that you see paying off seventy thousand
maybe your debt free scream today is
gonna wake somebody up you never know so
you'll have the book in your hand and
you'll be able to do that so good stuff
very proud of you guys your heroes thank
you well done
very well done all right rudy and tracy
from phoenix arizona 68 000 paid off in
19 months making 105 to 115. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one is that free
[Applause]
done you guys
very very well done
very powerful good stuff inspirational
couple i have so many notes here i mean
that was just so many mic drops and
revelations that they had on their
journey that i think will inspire people
for a long time well when you say
personal finance is 80 behavior and only
20 head knowledge
and then she says
i had to get reconnected
to my money that means she's observing
that yeah she's feeling that there's a
visceral thing that's happening there
that says i i didn't i was just kind of
living and my money was in the other
room
and now i've it's got it's right there
in my face and i've got to make it
behave it takes this uh sense of power
and puts it back on you yeah america
needs to get reconnected to their money
congress needs to get disconnected from
my money how's that for that's a whole
another problem dave we got to do one
time i did that with only 14 seconds
left and i can't really say everything i
want to say
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day colossians 3 23
whatever you do do it heartily as to the
lord and not to men
and landers said opportunities are
usually disguised as hard work so most
people
don't recognize them
there we go george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five brad is with us
in butte montana hi brad welcome to the
ramsay show
all right thanks so much for taking my
call i've been trying to get in touch
with the last few
weeks but thank you for having me sure
what's up
well because a couple years ago my dad
died but he left me and my brother
you're kind of muffled can you speak
directly into your phone please
oh sorry i'm out in the wind okay not
better yes sir
well my dad left some land for me and my
brother
but
i've been in construction and drilling
for
well and building houses for the last
i don't know
30
plus years i started really young i
started roofing when i was 12 but um i
got some medical bills and stuff like
that and that's really the only thing
that i got but i'm looking into um doing
like iras and everything but like for
medical bills and everything like that
can they go into an ira or cds or
something like that or what would be the
best thing to do with the money
can they go in you mean can they take
them if you don't pay them
well i've been paying on them but how
much do you owe in those bills
[Music]
if i cut everything up probably over a
hundred thousand
and how much is the land gonna bring
uh
probably right around a hundred thousand
mm-hmm
and how old are the medical bills
well i'm going back you know probably 10
15 years the newest ones i've probably
only owe
maybe 10 grand but a lot of them you
know those are the ones that you know
i'm fighting
because the insurance said that they
were going to pay it and then they
didn't and
you know it was for like river blazing
for my back and
stuff like that so i can continue
working yeah okay so if you paid that 10
grand out of the 100
then there's an
old bills all that are 10 years old that
are 90 grand
yeah
within the last you know
five to 20 years yeah
maybe
a little bit longer to 20 years let me
give you a principle okay
they're not going away until you deal
with them you can't hide
oh yeah i don't want to teach you some
kind of technique that gets you off the
grid that's not a goal
so the goal is let's wipe them all out
and clean them up
so here's the way i would do it i would
say probably that 10 000 is in the last
year i'd probably just write a check and
pay those
once you get through arguing with the
insurance company
all right okay now then you've got the
other ninety thousand dollars worth and
you got some work to do my friend
you've got some contact with them and
working working with them and you can
probably settle all of that for
somewhere around 10 cents on the dollar
so somewhere around another 10 or 15 000
would pay off your all of your medical
bills for 25 000 total give or take
yes
and you should do that
and now you got 75 000 left and you
don't have the monster in the closet
anymore
but that's what i'm trying to you know
think of what to do with the because
i've been in contact with uh no you were
trying to think of a place to put it
where you didn't have to pay the medical
bills no i just changed
no
you said if i put it in the ira can they
get to it
yeah no on that part but i'm also trying
i'm i just got to set up some time
because i uh contacted well i've been in
contact with a couple other people in my
area that
for investing in stuff
good
good yeah you should do some investing
with the money that's left after you get
these medical bills settled
and then you don't have to worry about
can they get to it so yeah click smart
vester at uh daveramsey.com or i'm sorry
ramsey solutions.com
and uh and it'll drop down a list of the
people we have in your area there and
some of them can sit down and help you
with the investing part of it and you
might check with one of our ramsey uh
preferred coaches that have been trained
by us and george i think they could
probably help him fight through the
settlement issues with those old medical
bills what do you think yes you got to
negotiate this stuff and once you get
rid of all this debt hopefully that's
all the debt you've got to get the
emergency fund in place if you don't
have that because i don't want you going
back into debt this is a once and for
all thing and then we can talk about
investing and work with a smart investor
pro so you can create a game plan to
actually do this stuff the right way
yeah but um
you you for 20 years have not paid these
bills
off and on
and so you're going to get back in the
habit of paying the bills
and getting them and it starts with get
the current ones cleaned up and then
having the emergency fund for something
else comes up
uh then you've got some money to cover
that and you make sure you get you know
an understanding of your insurance and
what it covers so you don't end up in a
mess again with them and you've got for
your deductibles and other things you've
got the emergency fund in place
so
really the people that get burned on
these things are
are
uh they get to get damaged the most
financially by these processes is if you
don't actively engage like it's a fight
and so like that insurance company
situation he's got he's got to get it
you got to lean in on those people yeah
you got to advocate for yourself and
fight this thing and you can't keep
kicking the can down the road because
the can is still going to be there yeah
and your toe gets tired that's true no
one talks about that
ryan is in cleveland ohio hi ryan how
are you
hey dave i'm doing so well it's uh good
to talk with you good what's up
well i'm just getting straight to the
point here um
kind of question about a used car
purchase so my wife and i we have 118
000
in student loans no other debt outside
of that and our take home is between 150
and 160
and we have two paid for cars
unfortunately one of them uh really
can't be driven anymore so we're just
trying to figure out why um a good price
um
you have to do an e-check and her or one
of the cars can no longer pass the
e-check why
uh computer issues is what we were told
one opinion
get a second opinion
and the computer costs how much to fix
well uh the mechanic that we were
talking to
mentioned it can be
up to a couple thousand
um and then he said that's no guarantee
that it's gonna you know start working
well sounds like we need a new mechanic
that sounds crazy expensive for a
computer issue so what is the car worth
um well the car is a salvage title so
depending on if we go to a dealer or
sell it
it could be up to maybe five thousand
but probably not much more than that
okay yeah you probably don't spend two
thousand dollars on this car
to fix it but i think i'm going to get
some other opinions and see if i can't
get this computer thing fixed and rigged
for a while longer is are there other
problems with the car
no it honestly it runs pretty well
nice car subaru legacy it's just
the computer issues our sensors in the
car
are really starting to pile up here yeah
yeah well i'm not spending two grand on
it i'm getting rid of it and buying
another comparable
comparably priced car this is not a
reason to go and buy a fifteen thousand
dollar car because you got a hundred
thousand
yep so you know if you want to flip it
over break even buy something in the 5
000 range pay cash for it if you can't
fix it for a grand if you can fix it for
a grand i'm probably driving it but not
for two grand
okay that makes sense to you i
appreciate it yeah that's great i really
appreciate the advice because it sounds
like it's not a bad car 500 or a
thousand dollars is worth throwing at it
but if it's gonna be two grand it starts
to it starts to not make sense anymore
and you want to bail out of it yeah and
they they take home 12 or 13 grand so
they could cash flow a comparable car in
a month and not slow down their debt
snowball much at all yeah and so if you
want to flip it over and just you're
tired of screwing with it buy you 5 000
that's fine but the thing you got to
fight is oh i got this huge amount of
student loan debt it's going to be a
little while it's gonna be two years
three years before you knock that out
sounds like then uh it's easy to go well
that's permission to go buy mama a nice
car yeah no it's not
no it's not it's permission to buy mama
a different car that rolls yeah with an
engine that turns that simple and it
passes the e stuff there you go
george george campbell good show today
thank you thank you don't forget folks
game plan tonight at 7 p.m central time
text game plan to 33 789 if you want to
watch the live stream that puts this
hour in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit thermzyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you